pas de patrouille quel est le problème
quoi vous répondez vous même vos apéros
et dire que je ne pensais même par les
yeux on peut faire quelque chose pour
t'aider peut-être oui tu m'appelles
liberty et nous appellent davanture
ville il s'est passé quelque chose de
terrible monsieur ehlinger vient d'être
élu maire
mais c'est le pire des maires de tous
les maires du monde s'il vous plaît vous
devez nous aider venez au plus vite
c'est le moment de s'équiper
[Musique]
c'est à toi de jouer utilise-t-on
grappin pour évacuer le chauffeur et le
mettre en sécurité
she's escient le court
[Musique]
mais c'est un ailier pas peur je serai
bientôt prêt vous remercient leurs
cibles possibles en fin d'été tout
joue pour être exact je suis un chien ou
un bébé chien c'est encore pire vous
êtes sûr choc je ne vais pas me vexer
pour sa
patrouille le fil seulement au cinéma